over what the accountability is how is a
man going to prison for not paying child
support for the betterment of the child
but yet you don't have an issue with
that which is the point i absolutely was
like i don't see that as okay but then
you can go jailbreak
here but exactly but if you go to if the
woman would have the consequence of
going to jail too she wouldn't do
certain things there are lots of things
in the american judiciary system where
i'm like that doesn't make any sense we
do not do that over here but they don't
vote so that's not something that
happens or because you can die
that's cool
do not agree with that like we're not
arguing over this i'm literally saying i
do not agree with that that should not
be the answer to not paying child
support because it's not in the
betterment for the child is it that
simple everything i've said is the money
and everything else should be in the
betterment for the child not for either
partner it's about the child that's why
it's called child support it's very
simple but would you not agree okay
let's take take america would you not
agree that if a woman if a man can go to
jail for not paying child support would
you not say it's fair for a woman to go
to jail for not allowing a man to see
his child
i don't think it's fair it's context
that the context
i don't think it's fair that anybody is
going to prison in this situation but
within the court
with the context by okay men are say men
are men are going to jail would you not
say in that society if a man is going to
jail for that would it not make sense
also for a woman to go to jail not
allowing him because the answer happened
to equal rights putting people in prison
that that it's not like what happened to
equal rights
but at this point you're just be the
controversial i'm not i'm not going to
agree with you because the answer isn't
anybody should go to prison the answer
is never that but we're saying within
the context that someone does go to
prison
should this be fair no
move on finally
move on
self self awareness is so important all
right my gosh so you're trying to say
that sending people to prison
i'm saying all i'm saying is it deters
people from bad behavior
yes it does it doesn't that's what it is
when i'm angry i'll never punch a man
because i know i'll go to prison and
there's consequences and that's you and
there are other people and most people
don't do that but that's that's what i'm
saying
any law enforcement officer will tell
you that if you increase the punishment
for a crime less people do it no i
disagree with that
wait so you don't think when class like
weed went from class b to class a there
was a dip in whether people would do it
what was selling weed
either
longer sentences for people being placed
but it doesn't it doesn't go in the same
way it doesn't go in the same way
because when you look when you look at
norway here their prison system is about
rehabilitation at the lowest offense
rates when america when they did the war
on uh war on drugs they just increased
imprisonment rates they didn't and loads
of make crime go down it's exactly that
so i don't but there was all sorts of
reforms you have to remember there was a
tipping point there was other reforms
that took place in places like norway
even portugal was another example
where they did criminalize yeah they
don't apply those same so so my next
question is similar okay
we're gonna go back to jail time
do you think if so
some studies say that up to like 20 25
percent of men are raising a kid that's
not theirs oh [ __ ] you know yeah what
that much
that's [ __ ] cool man said what one in
four mana reasons someone else is what
not knowingly no it's more like one and
three i think okay yeah one one in four
let's just say 20 on the low end okay
okay this is not this is in 2022. if a
girl does that knowingly or knowing that
there is a chance that that kid is not
his should she face prison time for
every year that that man wasted raising
a kid that wasn't his straight gunshots
oh
that's crazy
that's
that should be allowed at least one free
bag
one free you know just on the courts
okay yes yes or no
oh please what was it yes or no should
she face
jail time yeah
no
come on okay he wasted time resources
money she should waste the same let's
make it equal it's at least a fraud case
you know what i'm saying yeah yeah it's
fraud okay but yeah
yeah you could get jail time so if he
got her 16 years yeah and he was raising
yeah and she had been doing fraud it
would probably be four years it's fraud
i think it goes under for under fraud
okay yes and every child born speaking
to mike yes and every child born should
have a
paternity test because okay yeah i agree
yeah yeah that's a fraud and she should
go to jail hundred percent forward she
should get a receipt
case okay fraud straight to joe you know
okay
do we agree
now i want to argue no
[Laughter]
i've already like experienced
i i have experience with that and i do
think the girl should have gone to
prison yeah
she'll have to pay all that money back
as well that you spent you know wasn't
someone close to you
yeah yeah i was a good friend okay and
it was a long time
what happened was very painful so she
those are the she were you friends with
the girl other guy no the guy you're
friends with the guy and she how old was
the kit uh they had got to about eleven
eleven
[Music]
he ain't even the same he ain't the same
yeah
a couple men would jump off
how did he find out came clean she came
clean yeah 11 you know yeah and all in
high school
it's everybody else and it's it's
everybody around because they they are
kids that you all love as well so it's a
grandparents it's auntie uncles it's
everybody involved what would make them
come clean after 11 years though like
what happened like i think it was
conscious
wow years later you mean he lasted that
long and then all of a sudden the
conscience kicked in 11 years a long
time people were different
i find it interesting that when this is
something this is a topic that you know
it's affected you personally since you
know someone you
you're more so on our side but yeah on
the other ones and this is still this is
still a situation where we're saying the
woman should go to prison so the mum
wouldn't be in a child's life for a
certain period of time but yeah with the
other topic
of the damage that was caused was so
much and the other side of it is
monetary i don't place it the same if
the child is more likely to end up in
prison or
from being a single-parent household
even with uh most accord even with him
paying child support
that's still damage right
like what do you say so when it comes to
having having the man's child who
doesn't want the child
right
she's that child isn't a single parent
household he's still more likely to go
to prison even if he's playing child
support
yeah and i don't agree with that yeah
but the point is you know
we're just saying
a man shouldn't have to
pay for it if he doesn't want to but i
understand what you're saying what i'm
saying
the the deception
in this instance
had such ramifications on so many
different people's lives
that she should do time for fraud
if we can send people to prison for
flipping spending on credit cards
fraudulently mm-hmm
what she did affected loads of people
she should go to prison but even if
somebody's not even one person they'd
still go to prison
are we this i said it's not okay
he's trying to ascertain why you agree
with this or not the other one is
because you feel personally no um
attached to this situation because you
know someone has happened to you because
i know the people that it's affected but
that's what i'm saying that's the point
i will add the point that when we went
around the room she did agree with
everything we said for this specific
type of i know i know
but that was before we found out there
was a personal and no but that's why i'm
asking is it because of the personal
attachment 100 and it always knows
because the other stuff doesn't affect
her it's never affected us she doesn't
know how much it is and i clearly said
earlier on as well i have two cousins
currently going through that okay now
but
should the women in that situation go to
prison no fair enough i was trying to
ascertain why yeah no they shouldn't
it's that's an emotional thing between
the two of them and i and i get the
point but this was a a deception of the
highest order i think it's it's as bad
as like
the tinder spinner that's worse
than tinder
okay um
i think this was a really great show
guys